it's a that's a tough question because
on one hand
if if it's a continual thing of like
you're actively in my mind if you're
actively saying I'm not going to use
whatever pronouns whatever you want to
call it if you're not using someone's
pronouns like actively that is kind of
disrespecting someone but at the same
time
though it does cause emotional harm I
don't think
you should be going to jail or even face
a penalty for it because then this is a
whole thing of like where do you draw
the line between
yeah it's just the whole thing so I
don't think
that should be a crime I definitely
would not you know say it's not nothing
but I don't think it's a level where it
should be you know in criminal or civil
court